we have two defensive players of the
Year Award winners on the same team it's
not the first time that's happened in
the NBA but one of the most famous times
when Dennis Rodman joined Michael Jordan
and you know what the Bulls did that
year
I think I do won a championship
that defensive mindset for this team is
it needed much needed much needed uh
people you know we hear it all the time
it's a cliche you know
offense wins games defense wins
championships and it's true especially
when everybody knows everybody's plays
being able to get that stop when it
matters is very important now when you
were in Boston as a captain and a leader
uh you didn't hesitate to call some guys
out if needed can you do that here
definitely you know
you know and I think it's more I'm able
to do that and feel more comfortable
because you know at the end of the day
uh it's it's bigger than me and it's
bigger than us it's it's it's it's you
know we're trying to do something that
that hasn't been done here for these
guys and uh and that's just how I feel
being able to do that is because also I
hold myself accountable and I expect
that child to hold me accountable as
well so when you feel like that you know
you feel like hey you know I should be
able to to help you when when things
aren't going right and vice versa you
should be able to help me and it should
be No Malice behind that and that's just
how it is and as a leader you got to be
able to willing to to stand up and take
that and then also be able to give it
but taking it at the same time you are
going to be missing uh John Moran for
the first 25 games of the Season how do
you see your role adjusting when he
comes back
um very very very easy it's gonna be a
very smooth transition you know I played
on the ball in off the ball in Boston so
being able to come here play on the ball
and off the ball is something that I'm
used to and uh you know we're looking
forward and can't wait to have back on
the court you know he's a special talent
I think everybody in this world knows
how special he is and what he means to
this team and uh you know to be able to
have him on the court and be able to get
that that time in with him is going to
be huge for me and for this team and I'm
looking forward to it but my role is
going to be very easy you know and
having the guy like Jai and what he
brings to the table
last question is change good for Marcus
tonight change is always good for Mark
this morning I think change is good for
anybody uh but definitely for me you
know I'm a guy who loves challenges and
you know
once the challenge is done I need a new
one and this is definitely challenging
[Music]